[Music]
karora you may have heard of it you may
have not for those who you don't know
it's a place to share knowledge and
better understand the world since I'm
floor gang ow my brain 20% increase I'm
ready to share that knowledge today with
the world there's a Twitter account that
shares the good the bad and the ugly
from from Chora so I thought why don't I
chime in and give my best advice for
these poor souls with tiny stinky brains
here we have for example I don't like my
daughter she is disrespectful and very
negative she clearly does not like me
how can I get her to be more positive
and realize I'm not the enemy
throw her in the trash and get a new one
I don't like my daughter she says
brazzers would have an answer for this
no no hey listen up kids you got to
support the family only fames and only
my 15 year old daughter intentionally
doesn't sleep for days on end she says
she likes it when she starts seeing
things what should I do
how many they says it takes to start
seeing things asking for a friend
dude that sounds awesome let it do it
see what happens use your kids to
experiment on different things they're
basically like tiny versions of you that
you can duplicate so what do you got to
lose really I think I'm deleting my
son's Steam account should I really do
it when he has over 500 games no no no
no no Oh No
yeah you might consider eight that's a
lot of games yes free him from the curse
of gaming what the hell let it keep his
goddamn Steam account what's wrong with
you is it appropriate for a parent to
throw their 18 year-old daughter out of
their house because she is no longer in
school refuses to help around the house
our yard and it's very disrespectful
yeah this is what I've been saying just
throw them out you can always just make
a new one make sure you tell that to
your children you know what you're
replaceable okay I'm
I can make many of you I love how people
try hard these someone else
what fruit starts with the letter O I
can't think of any that's impossible
oh oh banana Oh Apple Apple is that you
saying people reply orange added a photo
orange is why they'd known and accepted
fruit all over the world so widely
accepted fruit
I don't accept the orange I don't and
I'm tired of being okay with it it is a
member of the Big B that's what you are
who Spencer day doing this I mean I'm
technically doing it but goddamn the
cringe what are some street-smart tips
that could potentially help me one day
always carry a few coins in your pocket
no that's super annoying they cling all
in your pocket and they always fall out
in your sofa this is terrible advice
if someone confronts you with a knife
you pull the coins ugly from your pocket
and drop them on the floor the attacker
will always look down oh oh oh
poins there's coins bro Jerry Jerry
there's coin they're getting away
but there's coins I thought like there
was some defense mechanism like you
throw the coins in their eye or some
machine this is awful always carry coins
how do I it's small pp this now you
can't smoke pou can't smoke PP what
happens when you stop eating sugar you
die you die instantly
any other questions there you go
answered no need to thank me what did
you learn too late in life books are
probably the best friend in life books
can help you gain tremendous knowledge
and help you when no one else when no
one can and I can't read now I agree
with this except that you have garbage
in what it stays the subtle art of not
giving up
ah it's everywhere read the Greeks read
the Greeks notice of a butcher about the
space this space will be about deep
thoughts that occur in your brain and
heart hence the name deep thoughts
my mind is ready to go blow this space
will be mainly poached for a thought
remain a few answers that have deep
thoughts literally no one has posted
anything thoughtful I'm trying to think
what I think is interesting about space
and deep thoughts I want to contribute I
think the fact that the Pythagorean Oh
what's called in English Pythagoras and
it's called the Pythagorean theorem that
eight squared plus B squared equals C
square it's an another example that math
is universal because it transcends time
and space no matter what time and no
matter what space a square plus B Square
will always be C square it's a universal
truth which i think is really
interesting you can draw on a whiteboard
the triangle obviously that will not
stay but the the theorem itself will
always remain the same I think it's cool
pp large is it okay to eat a lot for
breakfast for weight gain yeah you can
eat a lot that's the point of weight
gain no am I kidding this rod what the
hell I'm trying to gain weight should I
eat more food I don't know what to do I
have this style of I can't figure it out
drink a gallon of milk with every meal
until I don't want to be too weird never
mind why is my exercise not affecting me
if I'm doing exercise on a daily basis
lift harder beta come on all right
just kidding working out every day is
not always the most efficient try having
to rest days for muscles to recover but
also recharge your motivation to make
sure you are pushing you
yourself harder in your workouts floor
gang 20% muscle increase subscribe thank
you
hey look at that I was actually helpful
you're welcome Internet my knowledge and
science knows no bounds have you ever
seen a life ruined by an apparently
insignificant mistake yes yes every day
on the internet what disturb you today
seeing how avid people are on this
website
epic cringe bruh how important is it to
pay attention to one's eating habit
self-control is the key to unlocking and
like man I can't spell if you don't mind
what you eat you're just an empty vessel
if you're not mindful oh God
I'm becoming what these people are so
now I'll be telling people what oranges
are sacrificing every craving with
fleeting happiness a lemon bar burger
tastes good there you go you're welcome
it's Kim jung-un genetically naturally
fat or does he actually consume enough
calories to be as obese as yes I know I
know historically during famines it's
seen as more attractive to be more of a
weight as a status symbol
look I'm not poor I can consume lots of
food look how fat I am it was the same
with this skin tone back in the day with
people generally looking at some Tanis
that's poor people that have sometimes
because they aren't working all day look
how white my skin is so I assume it's
the same in North Korea but I can't tell
for sure and I'm too tired to write all
that out but you're welcome if you're
watching the video what happens if you
don't eat and just take vitamins you
will be able to jump between parallel
universes don't take too many or you
might not return good luck
why are people asking these questions
you get no nutrition you get enough
nutrition what that professor pretty pie
here to add some more karora questions I
found a bunch of extra ones and I'm like
damn why did I show that in videos I
thought
go through some more can i baby get
pregnant if you have sex during
pregnancy these are the tough questions
in life I don't know the answer of this
I don't think anyone knows I think my
all-time favorite is this one if Albert
Einstein was so smart then why did he
die chick mate rib rows huh
be so smarter than my dead he's dead as
hell your mama dead my macbook air
weighs 2.3 pounds if I download more
files on it will it make it heavier bro
I got at least 50 terabyte of enemy my
computer heavy as hell
I'll certainly understand why this
website exists now I get it
people need help why must we wipe our
own ass oh why I wipe my butt oh Japan
solve this issue already and I agree
100% why I have to wipe my ass it's 20
20 god dammit another great example why
kuroh rice is correct I'm sorry for
taking such a sarcastic and unserious
tone to this video do lesbians eat
vegetables somebody so dummy I don't
know if it's even funny
I want to slather my dog in chocolate
sauce but I don't want her to put any of
it in her mouth because you know she
died how do I prevent her from eating it
dear karora person why the oh god people
need help I'm sorry our girl asked me
what I wanted for lunch and I say pizza
but I really wanted steak why did she
bring me bass that's my answer so I put
that in written form
why should I aim to shoot at a van that
is fleeing my house with my girlfriend a
name where should I aim the tires you
dumbass what is that game from the
element was it on the Xbox where you
would constantly have to shoot the gas
tank to stop you shoot the gas tank the
whole car explodes I've seen it in that
xbox game 20 years ago it was great
if the earth-moon was replaced by an
equivalent sized banana what effects
would that have on earth we'd have an
epic thing to look up in the sky
stinky moon not a tech big come on
wasn't there Neil deGrasse Tyson tweet
that said if the craters on the moon
were as deep as we depict them in a lot
of artwork then our blood vessels would
explode so I'm pretty sure we would all
become bananas that's the answer is
there any pity pie questions I want to
answer pretty pie questions that's my
expertise well Pete if I get anything
for hitting hundred million subscribers
yes I did I got the pike it was pretty
cool it didn't look like that though
PewDiePie related what species of birds
are in Minecraft
we got a ikea bird one we got ikea bar -
and IKEA board three
how does pity pie manager earn six point
five million pounds every month from
YouTube I wish I made that much but I
think you are referring to god dammit
and old yearly declaration not monthly
stinky brain LMO didn't fight - ugh no
she's fine
stop asking what do you think a pity pie
from the vibes I get when I watch his
videos I feel like this is a decent
fellow prone mistakes as a human but
decent best Felix Kjellberg what the
hell cringe hey that's not that's me
Felix Kjellberg is ninja more popular
than pee no no I should've done this
sooner is so much more fun
what is something only PD PI fans
understand big PP tower of Tamborine
seriously it's one of the most
misunderstood people in the inner ear
right now I've seen most of the
misunderstood people in their internet
tend to be people in funny business
comic online comic creators I'm
surprised to see Korra
standing PewDiePie I'm sorry Korra I was
wrong you guys were pretty cool I was
wrong about everything
why is pre to fight some popular
children he's full of charisma he's
funny he has all the basic quote all
Mike big peepee if
I can get the nine-month-old on my
science then the things could be
different
it's PewDiePie's channel slowly no no my
channels doing great and we're beating
Coco leg reveal and 110 million oh I
forgot to show you guys I I fixed the
tambourine
so it's taller now I got flex tape as
you guys suggested very served sturdy I
gotta say the commercials were correct
and I gotta say it does look a lot more
attractive it works great now dissipate
if I have six-pack ABS yes yes yes yes
yes
how much does PewDiePie make per video
if I tell sigh he's gonna want to race
so I'm not gonna answer that one did
Mauryan pay paid by to play minecraft no
but terraria at least supported me
terraria a big peepee energy I gotta say
they posted me on Twitter and then in
tendo blog so big PP add to your
terraria how expensive it please please
check
$3.99 come on you should know that that
chair does not have epic custom
exclusive that's better PewDiePie
patterned line Oh their copyrighted now
as well pretty pattern lines they give a
sense of superior muscle increase around
10 to 20 percent why it's pity pie in
the center of so many controversies
because I've always had a very
light-hearted take on serious topics
which was clearly someone that is as
popular as I am should have seen that
coming
it was inevitable does that make it
right probably not but that doesn't make
me completely blameless either I've been
very reckless and not careful and I've
paid the price for it but now no more
controversy only epic that's a British
costume by the way just so we're clear
okay
what a pretty face political views you
just do it in Swedish interviews if you
ask me it's not interested in engaging
in politics look through his mother's
Facebook don't snoop through my mom
there's nothing political there either
they really broke this down even most
Swedish right-wingers dislike Trump
Trump's approval rating screaming what
the hell reason I don't get into
politics is because I find that it's
more based on all your evil oh no you're
evil Oh your Center will pick a side
it's just it's just become more about
name-calling instead of discussing
actual ideas of how to improve the
quality of life okay I'll let pity pie
from the past with a with a less epic
tambourine take over the rest of the
video oh you guys know situation what
thou goddammit Wow let's talk about
books read the Greeks and stop reading
books with F word in the title cringe I
feel like I'm actually helping here this
is great I'm enjoying this what are the
best novel under 200 pages Fahrenheit
451 well that's where you're wrong Sonny
Boy remove Fahrenheit at 51 Ray Bradbury
is the definition of a Boomer add the
sailor who fell from grace with the sea
I have no mouth but I would scream there
must be a [ __ ] cress in here no [ __ ]
face
no Jorge Luis boys add fictions on lists
man's search for meaning book of five
rings
the symposium Sun and steel would add
more can't be ours you're welcome what
are some great historical nominal day
Iliad it's hundred percent true how many
books can you read a day I usually read
three books at the same time while
listening to five different audio books
on different speeds but that's just what
I do which book of Hara haruki murakami
was the first one you read who [ __ ]
cares
IQ 84 1q84 and it's not that's a
terrible one to start with the region
Wood is a good one to start with I
always recommend Murakami if you're a
new reader because this is literature
it's quite easy it's easy to get into
and it has a lot of sex a lot of
underage sex in every single book every
time I read it Murakami become like
great this one doesn't have underage sex
in then oh god dammit god dammit like
Wow actually got more respect
for Murakami's writing he managed to
write a thoughtful novel without some
weird outward scene in it academy he
managed somehow why is the counter
Montecristi are so compelling it teaches
you that achieving happiness can come
from pain whatever pain you're going
through in life know that it will one
day bring you virtue it's a great book I
recommend it what does it mean for
someone to say you are like donkey shot
is it a compliment no they're calling
you stupid
so fun judging people online I love this
I wonder what to say by yukio mishima
this question presupposes that death has
value and if not done properly is
meaningless when in reality his death
was in fact executed deliberately and
we're too clean to give it just that
meaning boom
helping the world understand no one says
the pictures speak louder than words
buying a vehicle starting a family
homeownership Wow
deep does this picture say more than a
thousand words add one word to it deep
now I think it says one word I think
that what this picture says is it's too
many words I don't know I'm obviously
joking and coming across as very
know-it-all and deliberately playing it
up for the video just sorry it's clear
I'm not I'm just [ __ ] around I just
don't really see a point in any of these
I always felt like you can people can
tell you the answer to things but to
understand it is something that you
really have to discover for yourself so
I just find this whole page to be so
redundant unless there's some actual
factual questions and I always looked at
random information like did you know
that's this kind of obnoxious but that's
just me if you enjoyed this video which
I doubt you did but if you did hit
gently like bun appreciate it
I've become a member we're doing live
streams we've got exclusive merge a ton
of cool features I really appreciate
everyone supporting it's been really
great so far building a sub community
and I see you guys in two days cuz I
take two days off because boy was this
exhausting see you guys Hado
children of nine parts it's time to race
what was once forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
hope tears coming to Nintendo's wait and
remember it has a very big peepee
pre-order promotion I mean
yeah yeah we assetbook birthday girl ran
away
[Music]